MALE SPEAKER: Hello.
My name is not Reto Meier, and
welcome to this week in Android
Development, on Monday,
November 11, 2013.
Since our last episode of this
week in Android Development
aired, we've launched the
Android 4,4, our KitKat.
And if you haven't,
you should watch
the What's New in
Android Videos that we've
been recording in many
different languages.
We might even have a
recording in American
if we ever get around to it.
In addition to
what's new in KitKat,
there's a lot of awesome
DevBytes that we've recorded.
They're in one
convenient playlist
that you should watch as
well to get an idea of what's
new and improved in Android 4.4.
This week, the DEVOXX conference
is in session in Belgium,
where a few people from the
Android Developer Relations
team will be presenting.
Now, if you're on this
side of the planet,
Reto Meier will be
the keynote speaker
at AnDevCon in San
Francisco this Wednesday.
That's all for this week
in Android Development.
Be sure to check out
this week's bytes.
I am not Reto Meier,
and I hope you too
are having a beautiful day.